voters across the crimean peninsula have
been casting their ballot since 8am many
had already been waiting for hours when
polling stations opened today is a
holiday I'm so happy I want to cry my
sister is 75 and was born in the Soviet
Union all that time she has been
dreaming of dying in Russia and now she
says her dream will come true security
forces are keeping a watchful eye
outside polling stations trying to keep
a lid on any violence authorities here
don't want any disruption but observers
say those who oppose joining Russia are
unlikely to vote anyway such as people
in the town of jock riad Noah most here
are Crimean Tatars who have a history of
persecution 300,000 people belong to the
Muslim minority in the Crimea they are
boycotting the vote Sulaiman Chalabi F
is studying law in Simferopol he says
the vote is unconstitutional he's
concerned that the vote could be raped
mr. new preloader eluded them supporters
of Russia will vote two or three times
after all we don't have official voter
lists transparency or oversight of the
process the only election observers are
Russian and they're certainly not
neutral collusion with Dylan do go chill
ignore when you look at us but I did you
go through a charge the pro-russian
premiere of Crimea has denied sergei
aksyonov was one of the first to cast
his ballot in the morning
there is no pressure on people you can
see that for yourself people are free to
vote personally I haven't felt or seen
any pressure people can cast their votes
until 8 p.m. local time first results
are expected shortly thereafter results
that neither the interim government in
kiev nor the west say are legitimate